you know I've been traveling a lot  lately in the last year year and a half  gone to a lot of places our prime time  special Conan in Berlin is airing this  Wednesday I go to Berlin I have to say I  had a blast there I think some really  funny things happened here's a quick  taste a magician with you appreciate you  leaving your cuckoo clock to be here  because ESA zing in German  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  just one suggestion don't spread your  fingers like this  we know you have ten fingers  [Applause]  [Applause]  that is I  I swear to you I said that's the second  time in our lives we've done that yeah I  swear to you that is just the tip of the  iceberg there's so much madness in the  Berlin show check it out be sure to  watch our primetime special Conan in  Berlin airing this  [Applause]  you